Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy here to tell you the truth about
the Council on American Islamic
relations that is the notorious group
known as care care has promoted hate
crime hoaxes despite its continued
claims of a rise in islamophobia and
hate crimes against Muslims the reality
is that care has found itself repeatedly
trumpeting as hate crimes events which
either did not occur at all were hoaxes
or where the supposed hate crime was
merely cover for another crime such as
insurance fraud on multiple occasions
arson of Islamic centers reported by
care were in fact carried out by Muslims
who attended those Islamic centers in
some cases care has even listed as hate
crimes criminal prosecutions against
known or suspected Jihad terrorists in
one bizarre case care even included as
an American hate crime the death of a
Palestinian American in Jerusalem who
was shot after crashing a car into a
crowd of
Israelis the purpose of K's continued
trumpeting of what turned out to be fake
hate crimes is to deflect attention away
from the reality of jihad Terror and to
claim for Muslims victimhood status that
will gain them solicitude rather than
scrutiny from law enforcement this
strategy has succeeded magnificently
most notoriously in connection with the
Boston Marathon bombers mosque the
Islamic societ of Boston despite its
many connections to Jihad terrorists
before the Boston bombing the Islamic
Society of Boston was visited by FBI
agents only for the purpose of Outreach
that is to reassure Muslims that the FBI
was not islamophobic care has
consistently and systematically defamed
foes of jihad Terror as bigots and
islamophobes K frequently claims that
critics of jihad Terror spread hatred
and intolerance and demands that they be
denied a public platform for their views
use this is an extremely common tactic
that K and its allies group Allied
groups use to try to discredit every foe
of jihad Terror care makes a regular
practice of sending letters to hosts of
events asking that foes of jihad Terror
be dropped as speakers it frequently
publishes the texts of these letters in
its Daily News briefs email and
distributes them as national press
releases its targets have included
former FBI agent John guondo
counterterror expert Sam Koba University
of Central Florida Professor Jonathan
matusitz Iran expert raaza khili an
unnamed defense depart instructor
defense department instructor ex-muslim
Noni Darwish human rights activist
Pamela Geller and me care officials have
also engaged in anti-semitic and
anti-American rhetoric perhaps this
should come as no surprise given Care's
ties to Hamas but care officials from
the national leadership all the way to
its Regional chapters have a reputation
for trafficking in the viest
anti-Semitic canards care executive
director nihad Awad blamed Jews for
controlling us policy under both the
Clinton and Bush administrations Awad
has also said the Jews plan to distort
Islam's image and have succeeded in
their plans this Jewish plan had borne
hostility toward Islam and deforming its
image K Southern California head husam
IOU referred to Israelis as zionis and
compared American Jews who joined the
Israeli Defense Forces to terrorists who
join the Islamic State a comparison also
made by K San Francisco's Zahra Belo K
is also known to have hosted
anti-semitic and pramas clerics
including wagon yusf Al karada and basam
alamou who once told a crowd of American
Muslims in Chicago that they did not
need to seek a fatwa to kill Jews it was
okay to go ahead and do it without
one despite its name the Council on
American Islamic relations has never
insigned
seemed interested in fostering good
relations between Americans and either
American Muslims or Muslims worldwide
instead care officials go out of their
way to engage in rank anti-americanism
that's including condemning US veterans
on Memorial Day as care Michigan chapter
leader dawud wed and Zahra Balo have
done wed and Balo launched into a
Twitter diet tribe against US service
members on Memorial Day on Memorial Day
2014 wed described the us as being found
founded on white supremacy and was
quoted as questioning whether US troops
should be honored for dying in an unjust
War beloo said she struggled with
honoring those who died and retweeted
assertions that America was founded on
genocide and that Americans have a taste
for mass
murder this view of America is
encouraged by care that sees American
nationalism and patriotism as a threat a
threat in particular to its own control
over the Muslim Community
as care Florida representative Hassan
shii described it nationalism was pumped
into Muslim communities in order to
weaken and divide
us care officials have also perpetrated
perpetuated the myth that the West is at
war with Islam a major theme of al-Qaeda
and Islamic State or Isis recruiting
this view is part of a larger effort by
care to create divisions and isolate
American Muslims this is also the logic
behind K's continued Litany of claim
seems that the US is engaged in a war on
Islam care has done this in particular
in response to US Government action
against organizations caught engaging in
material support for the Jihad terror
group Hamas for example K described the
decision to freeze assets of the Hamas
link holyland Foundation likely to
create the impression that there has
been a shift from a war on terrorism to
a war on Islam this sentiment was echoed
when the FBI arrested care Texas leader
gash gasan alashi for terrorism Finance
over his links to HLF K called that
arrest a war on Islam and Muslims rather
than a war on terror nihad Awad
responded similarly to reports of the
law enforcement raid against the Safa
group a network of organizations
suspected of Terror Finance saying this
is a war against Islam and Muslims our
Administration has the burden of proving
otherwise Awad himself has repeatedly
referred to us counterterrorism efforts
particularly in response to government
action against other Muslim Brotherhood
and Hamas linked organizations in
exactly that way other care officials
have described the us as treating
Muslims like second class citizens and
compared the US to the regime of Iraqi
dictator Saddam Hussein care officials
have falsely labeled Muslims as under
attack facing a demonization of Islam
and that said that the US the FBI's
counterterrorism strategy amounted to
gather up the
Muslims government and media leaders who
still have Conta with care should
decisively repudiate this unsavory
organization I'm Robert Spencer for
Jihad watch